une commande pour remporter sans une
tonne de contenants qui finissent aux
poubelles c'est une option qu'on offre
maintenant aux clients dans ce
restaurant asiatique de Saint-Henri
essentiellement tous les plats qu'on
utilisait du plastique faite là-dedans
tu peux prendre un rifri un plat de
nouilles une soupe des pains vapeur les
consommateurs peuvent repartir à la
maison avec leur repas dans des
contenants métal consignés au coût de 9
dollars chacun si tu prends un T4 à 10
dollars
tu dois débourser 19 à la place de 10 au
final tu reçois ton neuf ça te coûte la
même chose et tu peux être fier de toi
d'avoir fait ton petit effort dans notre
grande lutte pour l'environnement
pour obtenir le remboursement de la
consigne les clients doivent reporter
les contenants dans des points de dépôt
situés à proximité des restaurants
participants comme cette épicerie zéro
déchet
ils sont ensuite amenés dans un centre
de lavage et une fois propre ils sont
redistribués au restaurateur le service
est offert par la coopérative retournez
l'idée à germer au début de la pandémie
quand les restaurants ont dû fermer leur
salle à manger et se tourner vers les
repas pour remporter
on voulait encourager nos restaurateurs
locaux mais à quel prix ont créé une
quantité astronomique de déchets c'est
un peu de lac est né l'idée en se disant
mais il y a certainement moyen de les
encourager nous rester du quartier tout
en évitant de remplir notre poubelle la
coopérative a lancé un projet pilote
dans l'arrondissement du Sud-Ouest au
printemps dernier en ce moment trois
restaurants un fromager et une épicerie
métro offrent les consignés et on compte
trois points de dépôt dans le secteur
j'ai Satie Brothers le système est en
place depuis environ un mois une
vingtaine de clients dont utilisé le
plus taf c'est convaincre quelqu'un de
l'essayer une fois qu'il essaye
sur soit ton argent après ça coûte rien
et je crois que c'est juste des
habitudes à prendre le consommateur
aussi a un effort à faire dans cette
boucle à rebours comme on appelle la
logistique à rebours en économie
circulaire puis on aura de
d'établissements participants dans le
quartier plus les consommateurs on va
dire participeront parce que ça sera
rendu juste normal la coopérative qui
veut étendre ses tentacules d'un
Rosemont et Villeret c'est récemment
lancé à la conquête du
Plateau-Mont-Royal aux six
établissements offre ses contenants
consignés
c'est le cas dans ce restaurant qui va
aussi du prêt-à-manger le propriétaire
qui avait déjà mis en place son propre
système de consigne aussi adopté celui
de retourner je pense honnêtement que de
plus en plus de restaurateurs vont s'y
mettre il y a quand même un
véritable engouement je le vois autour
de ma génération et les jeunes le sont
encore plus je suis assez optimiste
battu vraiment vraiment parce que juste
dans le quartier il y a énormément de ça
de zéro déchet devrack et les
réglementation de la Ville de Montréal
pourrait aider à compter de mars
prochain les restaurateurs ne pourront
plus utiliser certains contenants de
plastique comme ceux en polystyrène pour
y mettre les commandes on espère que
dans cette démarche de ce questionner ou
de se renseigner sur les alternatives
possibles le réutilisable soit une
alternative totalement sensée et qui qui
est considéré le changement est pas
toujours facile mais souvent il est
nécessaire que des restaurateurs et
leurs clients sur le tiennent pour dire